foreign
Smith
[Music]
he's someone I know well he's the author
of a world view that I held for most of
my life
I taught it to hundreds of people when I
was a missionary
it's a religion and a gospel that I
deeply believed in
one full of Hope and meaning and
community and unique stories stories
about where we came from and where we're
going
let me show you what Joseph Smith built
and how he did it
how a non-religious uneducated kid in
Upstate New York created a global
movement that would gather huge numbers
of followers in a very short time
and who were pushed out from town to
town
often with violence
I want to show you how these people held
on to the vision and Mission that Joseph
Smith taught the building of a new
utopian society one founded on Celestial
laws one that was preparing for the end
of the world and the second coming of
Jesus Christ so let me tell you the
story of Joseph Smith the church he
built and how that church and its
Mission still exist today
foreign
hey before we open up this large can of
worms that I've been thinking about for
many years I want to thank the sponsor
of today's video the people who make
this all possible thank you better help
for sponsoring today's video betterhelp
is kind of relevant to today's video
because better help is a platform for
therapy a few years ago I started seeing
a therapist every week not because I had
some clinical mental health issue that I
was trying to address but rather because
I wasn't feeling good I knew there was
things in my life that I needed to work
through and there are Professionals for
that going to therapy has changed my
mind it has changed my life it has
changed how I see the world and it has
made my life better very objectively
betterhelp is a platform that makes
therapy more accessible to more people
you sign up for better help you take a
quiz that kind of tells them a little
bit about you and your needs and your
goals and then they match you with a
professional licensed therapist that you
can start communicating with in as
little as 48 Hours you you can have your
therapy sessions as a phone call as a
video chat or even as a text message if
you prefer that if that's the most
comfortable version of therapy for you
if your therapist isn't a good fit you
can change to a different therapist for
free with access to betterhelp's Growing
network of professional licensed
therapists they have like tens of
thousands of different therapists you
can find somebody who's the right fit
for you all of this makes finding a
therapist much more frictionless than
the traditional methods a major
supporter of that goal because I believe
therapy is a life changer at least it
was for me so there's a link in my
description is betterhelp.com Johnny
Harris when you click that link to help
support the channel you also get 10 off
your first month of better help so you
can try it out at a discount see if it
fits for you so I'm grateful to better
help for existing but also for
sponsoring today's video with that let's
dive back into this let's talk about the
Prophet Joseph Smith
Joseph Smith was born in the perfect
place at the perfect time it was the
early 1800s and the U.S had just thrown
off England to become a new country it
was going through some massive Growing
Pains most of these new Americans who
had just left the old world rejected a
lot of Old World things namely religion
only 10 of white Americans regularly
attended church at this time so to help
revive God you have all these super
charismatic preachers who left the
cities and went out to the countryside
to preach and this led to an explosion
of religious thought especially in
Upstate New York so now you have all
these like hyper reformist religions
that were replacing old style
authoritarian type churches all these
new wild religious flavors that were
more emotional expressive and personal I
mean none of us were alive at this time
but you can kind of Imagine like this
brand new country founded on these new
ideals it was unprecedented times
America felt special and different but
also kind of scary Revolution in the new
world new science magical technology new
ideas both wholesome and sinful all of
it speeding up at an increasing rate
for a lot of people this was a sign a
sign that the end of the world was
coming and that Jesus like he prophesied
would come back to usher in this
thousand years of Glory for those who
believed in him and a thousand years of
fire for those who didn't this was
called the Millennium so a lot of these
new churches that were cropping up kind
of claimed to be the place that was
preparing the Earth for the second
coming like they were God's chosen
administrators on the earth in the final
days before it all ended it was scary it
was exciting and God was talking to
people again in new ways and this is the
context that Joseph Smith was born into
in 1805 born to a mother who was swept
up in the excitement of all these new
religions and a father who wasn't really
religious at all it's kind of like a lot
of people at the time a family that was
religiously lost but not for long
[Music]
in addition to being a frothy religious
environment Upstate New York was also a
place where people hunted for treasure
there was this culture of folk magic and
legends that led to the search for
riches and jewels that were potentially
buried by Spanish explorers or pirates
of the past or artifacts that were
hidden in Native American burial mounds
and their methods for hunting for all
this treasure were mystical and magical
they used Seer Stones crystals rods
Visions through dreams all of this to
help them locate Buried Treasure and
young Joseph Smith was very caught up in
this treasure hunting craze he wasn't
educated he barely had any schooling he
could kind of read and write he wasn't
religious but from a young age he showed
himself as a skilled treasure hunter I
mean let's keep some perspective in all
of our research we didn't find a single
like document showing that he actually
found any treasure but he managed to
convey to the people around him that he
was an expert treasure hunter using
mythical methods so this is the context
that you need to know to really
understand this story we're in Upstate
New York in the early 1800s there is
this frenzy of folk magic and treasure
hunting and the places Ablaze with
religious fervor and there's talk of the
last days and the Millennium of fire and
Glory that was coming any day now but
this story really begins in the spring
of 1820.
[Music]
Joseph a 14 year old boy gets curious
about religion and after visiting a
bunch of churches and finding no answers
he decides to go into a Grove of trees
to ask God which church was true this
movie that we're watching right now I
know by heart because I've watched it
hundreds of times of course dubbed in
Spanish I was a missionary in Tijuana
and the first thing that I would teach
people was this story and I would often
show them this movie I kneel down
and began to offer up the desires of my
heart so Joseph Smith is in this Grove
and he's praying
and after a run-in with the devil
exerting all my strength to call upon
God
he sees a pillar of light
brighter than the sun directly over his
head
and within that light he sees two people
whose brightness defy all description
and he finds out that it's God the
father and his son Jesus Christ and
Jesus goes on to tell him that none of
the churches that he's been
investigating are true and that instead
Joseph is being called to do the work of
God to restore the real true church that
had been lost from the Earth to restore
this church to prepare the world for the
second coming of Jesus and the
Millennium that he will usher in this
event is referred to as the first vision
and it is the founding story of the LDS
church the Mormon church like most
people know it as a member of the church
from a very young age you learn this
story you sing about it you talk about
it you study it and every few years the
church comes out with a new video
version representing the first vision
okay so this is just the beginning a few
years go by Joseph doesn't tell anyone
about his vision but by 1823 Joseph is a
late teenager and one night he's
sleeping in his like little humble cabin
with his family and he says that an
angel appears to him the angel is named
Moroni by the way if you ever see a
Mormon temple big white building you
will see a depiction of the Angel Moroni
on the top of that temple with a trumpet
pointing East but for now he's an angel
in Joseph Smith's room telling young
Joseph that yes the second coming of
Christ is right around the corner and
that yes just like God and Jesus told
him a few years ago he has been called
to prepare the world for the second
coming and if that wasn't enough Moroni
tells him that there is a book that is
written on Golden Plates that is buried
in a hill near Joseph's house the book
is an important record of a group of
Jews who left Jerusalem in 600 BC and
came to the Americas anyway I'll explain
that in just a second and don't worry
says Moroni along with the plates
there's the gear you need to translate
these plates into English Joseph just
needs to get a bit older and he'll be
ready to translate the plates at this
point Joseph tells his family what's
been happening and they believe him so
by the time he's 21 he's instructed to
go to the hill Kimora near his house and
get the plates okay so now Joseph Smith
in his 20s he's this uneducated
unreligious Treasure Hunter and he
starts to focus in on something totally
new in the words of one believing Mormon
historian Richard Bushman he starts to
orient himself away from Treasure and
towards translation he's becoming a
prophet
[Music]
so Joseph says he goes and gets these
plates and people try to Rob him but
eventually he gets them secured and in a
little cabin in rural New York Joseph
Begins the work of translating this
stack of metal plates that no one else
is allowed to see
[Music]
he would sit on one side of a curtain so
that no one else could see
and he says he looked through these
stones at the Egyptian Engravings on
these Golden Plates and they would turn
into English and then he would dictate
them out loud to ascribe sometimes his
wife or other early believers who were
supporting him and that scribe would
write them down at other points Joseph
didn't even need the plates to translate
he could hide them somewhere else and he
would use his personal Seer Stone the
one that he used back when he was just a
treasure hunter before he says he was
called as a Prophet this little
chocolate colored egg-shaped Stone he
would put it into a hat and then he
would bury his face in the Hat and he
said that the stone would light up with
the word that he was supposed to dictate
to his scribe his scribe would write it
down and the Book of Mormon was being
written now listen all of this seems
really weird and wild to us now very
easily like okay clearly this guy's
making it up but at the time mystical
visions and treasure hunting and Seer
Stones this was all very normal in
society folk magic Native American
artifacts none of this was very Fringe
and Joseph Joseph had been doing stuff
like like this for a decade which is why
his parents and other people in his
community supported him the difference
though at this time is that he was
blending his treasure hunting skills and
his folk magic sensibilities with this
religious revival that was happening at
the time to create something kind of
unique
so anyway he's in his early 20s he's
translating The Book of Mormon he faces
a bunch of ups and downs he goes through
a few scribes and after a very
productive 90-day window 24 year old
barely educated Joseph Smith finishes
dictating 588 pages of text that would
become the Book of Mormon
[Music]
Joseph says that he gives the plates
back to Moroni and then takes the
manuscript of the pages to a printer
that's how we have the Book of Mormon
This Is My Book of Mormon
Maps my early exposure
to maps
so the Book of Mormon is incredibly
important to this story because it was
the main validator for Joseph Smith in
those early days and continues to be a
foundational park for believers in the
LDS Faith that's because Joseph Smith
wasn't religious or educated and now
suddenly he's writing this bible-like
book in a few months and yes this book
is definitely full of a lot of like
full-blown copy and paste jobs from like
the Bible but there's also like a lot of
really compelling stuff in here in terms
of religious lessons complex histories
nods back to like an understanding of
Hebrew language and culture this is not
the type of guy that his town saw him as
he was a treasure hunter and a farm kid
not a religious man and definitely not a
prophet Mr Smith could you tell me more
about that book
yes
yes I could okay so let's be clear on
what Joseph Smith said the Book of
Mormon is it's not what a lot of people
say which is like the Mormon bible the
book tells the story of a group of Jews
in Jerusalem in around 600 BC they're
told to leave the city before it gets
destroyed so they leave the city they
walk in the desert for a while probably
till like Oman is what a lot of Mormons
think and then they build a boat and
travel across the ocean for a very long
time until they reach the Americas
somewhere in like North Central or South
America the foundation of the story is
about these brothers of the original
family who like eventually split off and
they're like hate each other and they
grow up into these two different
civilizations the Nephites and the
lamanites who are always fighting with
each other and there's all these
prophets and there's all this drama that
happens and the introduction to My Book
of Mormon says
the lamanites these people came over
from Jerusalem are quote the principal
ancestors of the American Indians and a
few years ago they did change that to
the lamanites being among the ancestors
of the American Indians but yeah the
point is that the Book of Mormon is a
history of these Jews turned indigenous
Americans and unsurprisingly there's a
whole community of believers who worked
to validate that this is actually a
historic record but no in reality
there's no archaeological genetic or
linguistic evidence that supports the
book of Mormon's assertion that Jewish
people migrated to the Americas around
600 BC
for believers the most important part of
this book is the climax of the whole
thing where in 33 A.D Jesus having
recently been crucified over in the old
world in Jerusalem gets resurrected over
there and comes to visit the people in
America which is where this Painting
came from this is a painting that is
hanging in a lot of LDS Churches it
shows Jesus Christ among the ancient
civilizations of the Americas yeah
some pretty wild stories
so yeah I know we're all over the place
and we'll get back to Joseph Smith's
life for a second but as someone who has
read this book dozens of times I can
tell you that when you're a Believer
this is a really compelling piece of
work you can read these Pages you can
read about the stories and the lessons
and the metaphors and you can take a lot
from it and the biggest thing that you
take from it is that it is proof that
Joseph Smith was actually called of God
to prepare the world for the second
coming that he was a legitimate prophet
so Joseph Smith by 1830 has the Book of
Mormon he has proof that he's a prophet
and he starts to gain followers
followers that believe him and a group
of those followers get together in April
of 1830 in a little house in Fayette New
York
and they start a church
at this point Joseph Smith is behaving
like a full-blown prophet he says he's
getting almost daily communication from
Jesus and he starts to develop a
theology that is unlike anything else on
offer
turns out that God is actually a man
with a body of Flesh and Bone and he has
a wife
God lives near a star that's far away
and we all of us here on Earth are these
little Eternal balls of light called
intelligences but our Heavenly parents
have birthed us into spiritual children
and then they sent us down onto this
Earth to get a physical body to get
married to create an Earthly family to
learn and to grow so that someday we can
return to live with god with our
families and then we can become like God
with our spouses we can create our own
spiritual families in some other part of
the universe but in order to do that we
have to pass some tests here on Earth we
have to complete certain rituals and
demonstrate obedience to him and in
order to make this all happen he needs
to set up a church the church needs to
have proper Authority and there would
need to be a savior that would come down
to account for all of our sins so that
we can be pure to enter the kingdom of
God again luckily one of our spiritual
brothers named Jehovah later called
Jesus volunteered to be this savior
okay but there's a big problem which is
that God's children are super rebellious
so over the years God calls prophets to
organize his church with the proper
Authority and to do all of these special
rituals to teach them about Jesus and
eventually that truth gets eroded and it
fades away and the World falls into
apostasy until it's ready again when God
calls another Prophet to restore his
authority and start the whole process
over again this happens over and over
until eventually Jesus came he was like
the sixth prophet he establishes his
church causes prophets and apostles
gives them the authority by putting his
hands on their head and then of course
he suffers for our sins and dies on the
cross but just like has happened over
and over Jesus's Church got corrupted it
got mixed with power and politics and
the world fell back into the apostasy
this one's called the Great apostasy but
eventually the world would be coming to
an end Jesus would be coming soon and
things were about to get really bad so
God help Europeans come across the ocean
to take over North America colonize the
land and create a country that had
freedom of religion also that a few
decades later Joseph Smith could be born
and then called to restore his church
and that's how we get to the first
Vision Jesus and Heavenly Father
appearing to Joseph Smith in a Grove
sending angels to him to tell him where
to get the golden plates and to solve
for the whole Authority thing Joseph
says that the apostles the original
Apostles of Jesus Christ came to him to
restore the authority that priesthood
that Jesus had given them so now he
could establish his church there was a
restoration Joseph was the prophet of a
newly restored church that he could talk
to God he could get instruction on
exactly how to run God's kingdom here on
Earth to prepare the world for the
millennium
okay that was a lot and let me just say
that was a very summarized version of
LDS theology someday I'd like to make a
video about the details because it's
actually super complex and super wild
the point I'm trying to make here is
that Joseph Smith's church did indeed
have a lot of the ingredients of the
religious movements of the time last
days apocalypse preparing God's Kingdom
on the earth preparing for the
Millennium this was all trending at the
time this was not surprising but a lot
of this stuff was totally new wild
Fringe Doctrine God has a body and a
wife this was a completely Wild Blend of
Jewish mysticism American folk magic
reincarnation Evangelical Christianity
and eventually he even woven Freemasonry
a totally fresh thing there was nothing
quite like it it was super unique and
super potent and super polarizing you
either believed that Joseph Smith was an
incredibly inspired Prophet who was like
revealing the truth that none of us had
ever heard before or he was just a
brilliant creative Visionary inventing
this elaborate plan to dupe people which
is what a lot of people in his village
started to think as he started to gain
followers they had him arrested calling
him a disorderly person he eventually
gets released and he realizes that he
and his few members need to leave
[Music]
this Begins the long journey of the
Mormons moving West Joseph and his
followers set out he's now talking to
God directly all of the time and he says
that the Lord is telling him to go to
Ohio to await instructions for their
actual Final Destination the place that
they're actually going to set up their
new city their Millennial Kingdom this
communal utopian society that would be
the base for preparing the world for the
second coming of Jesus
they would call it Zion
and this is the most important part of
the entire story Zion
if you want to understand Joseph Smith
and if you want to understand the rest
of the Latter-Day Saints movement
including modern Mormonism you have to
understand Zion
[Music]
Joseph says that the Lord is telling him
that he will give him the exact location
of Zion and he tells him that it will be
quote on the borders by the lamanites
remember that the lamanites are the
American Indians and so this actually
works perfectly
because at this time the US government
is ethnically cleansing North America
and pushing first Americans West so
there's a lot of territory where white
settlers are butting up against Native
Americans Zion is going to be somewhere
around here so Joseph and his followers
are now in Ohio and they are growing
people love this story and the concept
of Zion transitions from this sort of
vague idealistic idea to a very solid
plan a new society called the New
Jerusalem the New Jerusalem from the
Prophecies of old and it literally
became a plan like he actually starts to
sketch it on paper
we got these digital scans of Joseph
Smith's sketches of Zion
[Music]
he writes in extreme detail on exactly
what this city will be this whole thing
was based on these gritted streets on
perfectly parcel plots on no more than
one square mile of land Joseph writes
that the home should be 25 feet from the
street to leave room for a yard and
plant Gardens all the houses were to be
brick or brick and stone and there
should be Farms all around this city
that aren't too far the central streets
of this city nod to Joseph's love for
Jewish history and culture Zion Street
Jerusalem Street Bethlehem Street with
the temple in the center of the city
spoiler alert this is how Salt Lake City
and a lot of cities in Utah are actually
designed but that's for part two I mean
what this shows is that Joseph was
taking this idea of God's restored
Kingdom on Earth totally literally and
it was gonna be hyper Progressive a new
communal Society where everyone would
share with one another the resources
would be shared and the whole thing
would be governed by Celestial laws and
governmental structures a new government
run by the prophet where God could talk
to his people while he prepared the
world for its end Zion was a vision that
Joseph was uniquely good at rallying
around charismatic and creative leader
prolific and inspiring his followers
became deeply dedicated to this mission
of establishing Zion and it becomes the
main calling card for new converts
Joseph Smith's Millennial kingdom is the
place to be when the world ends and the
world's ending any day now
so the church is growing in Ohio they
still don't know where the final
location of design is going to be and
meanwhile Joseph is getting more and
more and more of these Revelations and
he's pushing the belief system of
Mormonism further and further from
mainstream Christianity Joseph comes out
and says there actually is no heaven and
hell but rather there are three kingdoms
of Heaven all of us will be sorted into
these different kingdoms depending on
how obedient we were here on Earth how
much we accepted Christ and repented of
our sins there's even a spiritual prison
and Paradise that you go to after you
die but before you're sorted into the
kingdoms in order to get to the highest
degree of Kingdom the Celestial Kingdom
you have to be married by the proper
Authority that will seal you to you and
your family forever and soon Joseph says
that more angels are appearing to him to
give him the authority to do this
sealing thing family is becoming core to
Mormon theology
but the good times don't last
the locals in Ohio and their government
don't love this vision of a new
religious Society the flocks of new
members of the church arriving to this
super well organized efficient unified
group of people led by this charismatic
Prophet who has more and more Fringe
beliefs one night Joseph is violently
dragged from his home by a mob he's
covered in tar and Feathers they're
telling him to leave and he does luckily
one of Joseph's missionaries and former
scribes Oliver cowdery had been out
scouting where Zion should be where the
millennial Kingdom should be set up and
he comes back and says he found the
place Jackson County Missouri 800 miles
away indeed and just as the Lord said
right on the border with the lamanites
this would be Zion the Lord tells Joseph
the place where he has appointed for the
Gathering of the Saints and now there's
a revelation from the Lord saying that
all of this land in Independence
Missouri should be purchased by the
Saints buy up as much land as you can
this is Zion Oh and it is revealed to
Joseph that this area Independence
Missouri Jackson County Missouri is
right next to the original Garden of
Eden like where Adam and Eve like the
first people were it turns out that
Missouri is like the Holy Land the
epicenter for the end of the world and
the Garden of Eden is in Missouri
[Music]
so Mormons start buying up land and they
start moving to Missouri and they did
this quickly this wasn't theoretical
they thought that the second coming was
like weeks or months or just maybe a few
years away Martin Harris one of the
early converts asserted that quote in
four years every religion in the U.S
would be broken down and all would
become Mormon and that the rest of the
human race would just perish and then he
was so confident that he said that if it
didn't happen he would cut off his own
hands I mean they were serious about
building Zion in Missouri and quick okay
but not so fast the locals like are not
into this they hear about this swarm of
Mormons coming to their County who want
to turn their City into a new religious
communal society and prepare for the
apocalypse and now they're arriving by
the thousands which means they will have
more political power soon they start to
get scared that the Mormons are plotting
a takeover of their private property all
in the name of building Zion and they're
not going to stand for it they want the
Mormons out so they start sabotaging
them with violence vandalizing their
stores destroying their homes assaulting
Mormon leaders it gets really violent
and at first Joseph tells his followers
to not fight back and once again the
Mormons are driven out
the next five years are years of
conflict for Joseph and his growing
Church they're on the move all over the
Midwest at each stop facing violent
resistance from local residents and
government officials so Joseph and his
followers are done being passive they
start fighting back and it escalates
into basically a full-blown War the
governor of Missouri issues a literal
extermination order saying quote the
Mormons must be treated as enemies and
must be exterminated or driven from the
state if necessary for public peace it's
getting really bad so they flee once
more to Illinois where the government
who includes a young lawmaker named
Abraham Lincoln gives them a special
Charter to create a city and a
government that is fit for their unique
Zion principles they call this city
Nauvoo Hebrew for beautiful or beautiful
place
okay so even though the Lord had said to
Joseph that he had prepared Missouri to
be the place for Zion the saints were
going to have to settle for Illinois for
now and they feel safe protected by this
Charter and they start creating Zion
there's a total merger between church
and state a complete religiously Run
Settlement where Joseph appoints himself
to be in charge of the courts as well as
the newly strengthened militia they now
have a full Army to protect themselves
Joseph had been sending missionaries to
Europe to preach about the gospel and
invite people to come join his vision of
Zion and one of those people is my like
great great grandfather who was
converted by a missionary in England and
then traveled to the United States with
his family and pregnant wife in pursuit
of finding Zion and they arrived to
Nauvoo a city that eventually grew to be
more populous than Chicago and it's in
Nauvoo where Joseph says that an angel
appeared to him and demanded multiple
times against his will that he take on
multiple wives that those wives are
sealed to him his first plural marriage
is to a teenager and he goes on to have
40 wives in just three years many of
them were married to other people but
then were sealed to Joseph the prophet
what I find striking here is that up
until this point you have this
meticulous documentation of every single
Revelation and theology Rule and new
policy in the church here in What's
called the doctrine covenants but
polygamy stayed quiet and private it was
one of those Revelations reserved for
just Joseph and the leaders that he
chose
by 1844 the Zion dream is actually
Catching Fire it's growing in Illinois
and Joseph decides to run for president
now he didn't have a big chance of
winning but in his mind and the mind of
his followers this was the natural Next
Step they were establishing Zion and
Zion was going to be the new Society on
Earth but this presidential campaign
miserably backfires because now he is
seen as a legitimate political threat
he's too good at gaining new followers
it gets worse when one group of former
Latter-Day Saints who didn't agree with
Joseph decide to publish a newspaper in
Nauvoo that criticized him for polygamy
and generally his leadership Joseph is
done messing around at this point he's
become very militant and he responds by
sending his militia to destroy their
printing press he declares martial law
and now the government of Illinois who
had given them this sort of safe Charter
seized this chaos and they're not into
it and they arrest Joseph for attempting
to cite a riot now this was one of many
run-ins with the law that Joseph Smith
had to uncover them some of them were
legitimate some of them were trumped up
but now he's caused a real disruption he
gets locked up in jail and two days
later a mob of more than 200 men stormed
this jail they climb up to the second
floor where Joseph and his brother are
and they shoot at him he tries to jump
out the window and he falls to his death
the prophet is dead at 38.
Joseph Smith is now a martyr he died
with a book of Mormon in his hands
defending his vision his belief in his
own story
[Music]
this poured fuel on the fire of his
vision for Zion but the Latter-Day
Saints start to realize that if they're
going to build Zion it's not going to be
in the United States they need to look
further afoot they need a place far away
where they can build their Millennial
Kingdom without being harassed for it so
they look far to the west to Mexico and
the next chapter of the story is the
move into Mexico and the establishment
of their Zion next to a large salty lake
in the high desert and that is a story
I'll tell you in part two but for now I
want to just tell you my thoughts on
Joseph Smith as someone who spent most
of my life believing this story basing
my life and my world view around it
doing this story and looking at it from
an objective historical lens
has taught me a lot
Joseph Smith created something really
powerful you can't deny that it was a
story about the last days it was a story
full of treasure and visions and angels
and modern day Revelation from God it
was a story about a chosen people
a utopian society of one heart and one
mind
safety Enlightenment there's a reason
why every year Latter-Day Saints go back
to that hill in Upstate New York where
Joseph said he found the plates and they
put on this insanely ambitious
production on a stage that's like 10
levels deep with almost a thousand
characters where they reenact the story
of Joseph Smith Their Prophet they
reenact him finding the plates
translating them and then they act out
the story of The Book of Mormon there's
a reason why Latter-Day Saints sing a
song called Praise to the man where they
laud Joseph Smith the prophet who opened
the last dispensation who restored the
truth to the world
I believed this I believed this well
into my 20s I found deep comfort in it I
found community and being a part of a
religion that was so different than
every other religion and that was very
often mocked for it the martyrdom and
the persecution of Joseph and his
followers became proof that this was
true and that it was being persecuted in
these last days just like the prophecies
in the Bible told us about
and I was compelled by this idea of the
last days the problem with getting
caught up in the Beauty and the comfort
and The Narrative of being a chosen
people in the last days is that
it allows you to ignore
I think that's what a lot of people have
done over the decades with Joseph's
story they ignore they ignore something
that I guess is plain for me to see now
on the other side of this
[Music]
Joseph Smith was a charismatic leader
who knew how to tell stories about magic
about visions and about treasure he had
known how to do that since he was a
teenager well before he decided he was
going to become a prophet he found an
audience in doing this he attracted
people to him with his Visionary skills
and he used those skills to invent a
complex set of stories about Native
Americans actually being Israelites
about Heavenly parents preparing the
world for its end and about the
priesthood this Authority that we all
must participate in to receive the
rituals and ordinances that only one
church can administer and eventually he
used these stories to build a movement
around his vision that allowed him to
take 40 wives and build an army and
break laws and Bully his enemies when
you are a Latter-Day Saint these facts
are written off as anti-mormon
literature or persecution but for me
having left the church and spent years
rewiring my brain and my programming of
these stories I see them as facts and
frankly they're not that surprising this
is the same old story of a charismatic
Visionary man who tells a story of
apocalyptic endings to gain followers to
gain power and then decides that he
deserves a lot of women and then he dies
for the cause leaving a movement that
continues his vision oftentimes those
movements get more and more dogmatic
they use shame to keep their people
close to them and
they Revere their profit
long after that Prophet is dead and yet
what's complicated about this is I can't
help but feel a deep sense of sadness
for having lost my belief in Joseph's
story
I can't explain it but these stories are
incredibly comforting when you believe
in them they are motivating these
creative stories unlike any other belief
system
can be really beautiful and that is a
paradox
that there's really no resolution for
there's a lot more to say on this but
I'm gonna save it for part two on this
series where we see what happens next
after Joseph is murdered and the
Latter-Day Saints move west to find
their vision of Zion
[Music]
okay
well
thanks for watching if you're still here
um I know that was a bit of a emotional
roller coaster uh there at the end
especially if you are someone who is
associated with the church in any way
and there's a lot there and I know in
making this video I felt a lot of
feelings and rehashed a lot of things
but I think doing it telling this story
has been pretty cathartic for me and I'm
really looking forward to the discussion
in the comments about what others feel
about this stuff let me tell you about a
couple things number one
um I'm really grateful for those who
support us over at The Newsroom The
Newsroom is what we call our patreon it
is a community of people who support the
independent journalism we're doing here
on the channel Newsroom members get an
extra video every month
um it's a vlog that is a behind the
scenes look at what it's like to be here
in the studio with us running this
independent journalism Studio on YouTube
which is a fun experiment you meet the
people behind the scenes you see our
processes you see our Shenanigans it's a
good time you also get access to my
scripts and some music but most
importantly late the people who were
there are mostly there because they
believe in what we're doing and they
want to support which is awesome also
I'm really into Maps which is not new to
many of you I designed a poster that you
can have on your wall it is called all
maps are wrong and it displays like 96
different map projections the different
ways that you can show our spherical
globe on a flat plane so that is for
sale I think we sold out but I think
we've ordered a new batch so that should
be for sale I hope it's for sale I hope
it's not sold out if you're like a video
photo person we have Luts and presets
which are just ways to color your photos
or your videos the way that we color our
photos and videos we developed these
with a professional colorist they
reflect kind of our look and feel you
can buy those and support the channel
and use them at the end of the day you
being here commenting showing your
support showing your love watching these
videos uh is the best way that you can
support us so I appreciate you being
here and we're just going to keep making
lots of videos thanks for being here
talk to you later bye
[Music]
thank you